just before the holiday season Queens of
the Stone Age from an josh homme me
kicked a female photographer in the face
during their k rocks almost acoustic
Christmas show in LA
Tommy later released an emotional policy
claiming he was a total dick and that he
had to figure some stuff out but before
josh get issued that statement the
killers frontman Brandon Flowers used
time during their set at the same event
to tell photographers not to worry but
they're safe and respected at the
killer's shows yeah sounds great right
except many photographers called
foul-play saying Brandon the killers are
notorious for kicking photographers out
of the venue during their performances I
feel like I haven't had the chance to
address it really I was being kind of
snide I wasn't being I wasn't trying to
capitalize on it yeah
I don't allow photographers that are on
gigs right right okay I wouldn't kick
him in the face but I don't allow him at
the gigs I'm just being funny he's
playing it doesn't read right when I'm
trying funny when I'm ironic in songs
people think I'm being sincere trying to
be funny on say everybody's just taking
it things too so damn seriously it's
been 14 years since the killers debut
album hot bus turned the Las Vegas
natives into household names
the album produced several commercially
successful songs and garnered five
Grammy nominations but it's the band's
latest record wonderful--wonderful which
finally earned them their first
number-one on the Billboard 200 but not
everything seems to be so wonderful for
the group last May bassist mark Stoermer
opted out of touring to return to
college and later guitarist Dave Keuning
followed suit to spend time with family
fans kind of went into a tizzy when you
know they found out that the other guys
want to be touring this time around you
had to be like whoa like relax we're not
you're not breaking up yeah but at any
point did you think well they're taking
a break maybe it would be nice to even
like rest little bit longer be home with
the family spend a little more time off
the road and that never crossed my mind
this is what we do yeah and it feels
weird not to do it and we've already
taken enough time off but you know
touring isn't for everybody
people have different things going on in
their lives and we respect that and but
we still want to do it
that's so many hits like so many hits
that people can sing along to and and
can dance to and now you've got this
album wonderful wonderful that's finally
number one when you're going through the
process of experimenting and finding
that new sound are you getting pushback
from anyone from from the label or
anybody else to work with even really
lucky I think because of the success of
the early record you don't have that
kind of relationship with the label they
know that we're gonna deliver it when we
feel ready and we've never really felt
that that kind of pressure
[Music]
as you go along in this journey you get
older and you start to sort of be more
comfortable opening up and being
personal in your songs and in your
reading how does that actually affect
the people that you're reading about
like you're really stuck with your wife
your relationship with your family when
you're reading about your experiences
and their experiences on an album
they're just being open about it was
helpful and with me and my wife she was
aware about you know what was what was
going on and what the context was and
how much she was gonna be a part of the
record and at first she was hesitant
about it a little bit but you know the
songs grew and they were beautiful and
ended up you know convincing her I have
two kids at home your father of three
and Mike I can't get my kiss swatch
anything I do like they don't they don't
care me with your kids at home are they
are they interested they're very aware
of it and they know a couple of the
songs but we don't really you know to
them it's just what their dad does and
don't try it we try not to glorify it or
anything the guy of music and performing
in there but if they ever said one day
this is what I want to do like I want to
do what you do dad what would you say
I've joked before and I've said you know
I would tell them to run you know don't
do you know the odds aren't any favor
that oh I don't think I really would do
that I mean you know a couple of them
are musically inclined and I don't know
if it's something that gets passed along
or not but you know I think it's a
wonderful thing it's blessed my life and
music is just in general I think you
know is it as a positive thing and I
would I would tell me give it a job
[Music]